I always wanted to be an actor ever
since I was seven or eight years old
just didn't seem to be an option we
didn't know any actors when I was
growing up my dad was a builder my mom
start off as a barmaid it just didn't
seem to be something that I could do
when I went to university and met other
people who said they were going to do it
and it became actually something that
was possible I kept at it I just yeah I
think it's in you from the beginning you
want to give it a go you don't I wanted
to my first audition was up several
flights of stairs in Soho and there was
a sweaty middle-aged man with a video
camera and he said take off your top say
your name and growl like a tiger which
I did probably most Pharisee thing I've
ever done this is this sound a bit
creepy
I don't know this is too creep anyway I
got the job it was it was a chewing gum
commercial for Estonia it's always
interesting ending a script because
first of all you either have a reaction
to it you think I love this story I can
understand this story or you it's like
meeting people really sometimes you meet
people and you instantly get them and
you click and other times you meet
people and you just can't see they're
just not your cup of tea and you're
probably not there so when you find a
script that you relate to and you love I
find as you read it you're instantly
having ideas about how you might play it
and sometimes that's exactly how you end
up playing it but sometimes then you
talk to the director and you go through
the read through and you have rehearsals
and you sort the other actors and see
what they're doing and it can radically
change and I think that's one of the
things I love about this business and
being an actor is that it's a team
enterprise I think it's hard for people
to realize how much work from so many
different people goes into a production
I mean you only have to look at the
credits at the end of a film or a TV
program see dozens and dozens of people
and the coordination between them all is
so fascinating the art director aware
script has taken and someone you know
decides what the room looks like they
decided what the props are going to be
every single prop us to be chosen the
costumes are going to be down to the
finest you know what sock someone is
wearing and it all has to be part of an
overall vision
it's the army of people and the
brilliant way they interact and the way
that all those creative processes are
all tied together to create the show or
the film the job of an actor is to say
lines as if they've just thought of them
that minute or to listen to surprising
bit of news and imagine you haven't
heard it before and it's hard you can't
go away as an actor and decide your
whole performance in front of the mirror
and then just come out and deliver it
because you're not listening or paying
any attention to what the other person
is doing in the scene so it's a really
weird process of learning the lines you
know them inside out and then almost
forgetting and just doing it
and listening properly to what the other
person is saying and hopefully something
surprising will happen you're always
looking to be in a in a in a room or on
a set or in a studio where you feel you
can say whatever pops into your head and
someone's not going to turn around and
go what what what do you mean you know
you you want a space where you can just
go this is just occurred to me what do
you think of this idea I'm very much an
actor up lots and lots of ideas some of
them are good some of them aren't and so
you're looking for a director to have
the taste and that in you know the
foresight to go that's good do that
don't do that some writers will not let
you change and hand to a butt or a you
know they won't let you change a
syllable they want it absolutely as
written you always have the option if
you don't think a line work so you can't
have going to the writers at the writer
and say I'm having I'm struggling with
this particular line I don't know how to
do it and that always happens I mean
there's no one answer to it that's the
beauty there's not a right way in a
wrong way there's a Fifty Shades of Grey
there's all sorts of different ways of
doing every single line and interesting
actors the ones I love to watch
surprised you constantly by saying
things you know on the page you would
never think of saying them like that but
they find something original interesting
to do with it and that's why they say
watchable writing is really tough and
the only way you ideally want some angry
and aggressive people threatening to
kill you unless you write it it's really
hot it's real easy to progress to me you
just need to get over the fact that what
you write might initially be rubbish you
just need to start and that can be so
difficult because no one wants to write
something that's rubbish sometimes you
have to start with something that's
rubbish once you've got something down
then you have something you can work
with and then go away and come to it the
next day or the next week go okay that
works that doesn't like any job you
don't want to do in life the hardest bit
is starting once you start then you're
off and you can deal with it I always
think it's you know if you wake up and
you haven't slept much the night before
the hardest be is getting out
but once you actually swing your legs
around and get out of bed the rest of it
kind of takes care of itself you just
get on with it
but it's that moment you're lying there
thinking oh God do I have to get up and
it's like I was writing you said looking
at the computer thinking just write
something put something down you may
throw that all away but at least you've
started the latest TV show that I'm
doing is hangups
which will be on channel 4 and it's a
comedy series which I have co-written
and I executive produce and I also star
in it so if it doesn't work it's my
fault
hang-ups is about an online therapist
who is dealing with all the issues of
his clients and also a huge pile of
personal issues in his own private life
I didn't come up with a concept it was
actually originally a show in America
written created by Lisa Kudrow called
web therapy and we were offered the
chance to remake it here and originally
I thought that wasn't something I wanted
to do because on the whole with a few
notable exceptions the first iteration
of an idea is normally the best one but
I quickly realized that you could take
the very basic concept of an online
therapist and completely rework
everything else about the show and come
up with something very original and very
British and very contemporary the only
thing that you can say about comedy is
you have to be able to recognize when
something's funny and when it's not and
that's something I think you're just
born with you know people call also
funny bones whatever it is but I think
you just have an instinct and a feel for
what's funny
other than that who knows I mean it's
really mysterious and it is difficult
you know drama you have to have
interesting characters with a plot that
works and a storyline that grips people
and then comedy has to do all that and
be funny on top I don't know how it
works I wish I did it's very hard to
give advice because everyone's career
and path through the business is so
different but
I think if I was going to give advice it
would be three things beyond time work
hard don't be a dick I think I probably
applies to pretty much every job but I
think if you follow those three things
you'll probably again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]